[Music]
it was a moment to celebrate Tyree
Nichol's Life In gospel and prayer but
also in sorrow
when those
monsters
murder my baby brother
they left me completely heartbroken Gone
Too Soon Nichols was 29 years old and a
father of a four-year-old child
he liked skateboarding with his friends
and he was an amateur photographer he'd
take pictures and post them on his
website
he loved his mom so much he tattooed her
name on his arm and often would rush
home to eat with her on his lunch break
while at work
at the memorial service some parents of
other African Americans killed by police
were in attendance Nichol's mom called
for new laws to swiftly punish police
accused of killing innocent people
because there should be no other child
that should suffer the way my son and
all the other parents here
have lost their children
You Are My Strength it was a memorial
attended by over a thousand people
including the vice president let on
memory of Tyree
shine a light on the path toward peace
and justice
so far 12 people have been disciplined
for their involvement in Nichols death
including five officers who have been
fired arrested are facing charges of
among other things second-degree murder
at the memorial service there was praise
for the Swift action but also calls to
end the overuse of police force in the
name of fighting crime you don't fight
gang
by becoming five armed men against the
unarmed man
I think the police that's punks
in America another memorial service for
another black man dead at the hands of
police this time his name Tyree Nichols
full of so much life taken away by the
very people who are supposed to protect
it
Gabriel lozondo Al Jazeera Memphis